next on public lives tom Chaffin charts
the course of the mapping of the
American West through the life of
Explorer surveyor businessman US Army
officer politician and abolitionist John
Charles Fremont this talk from the
Margaret Mitchell house and Museum in
Atlanta is an hour I'd like to thank the
staff of the margaret mitchell house and
a museum for hosting tonight's event and
i'd like to thank all of you for for
coming out and thanks to to the viewers
joining us this evening through c-span's
book TV i'm glad to be with all of you
the calls were gathered tonight in a
space associated with one of the South's
most celebrated creators of fictional
narrative I'd like to begin by telling
you that while John Fremont the subject
of my new book Pathfinder and like
Margaret Mitchell by the way a native of
Georgia is not a fictional character he
does in a sense have certain fictional
underpinnings to wit the moniker
Pathfinder a title pinned on him by the
press of the 1840s derives from the
title of an 1840 novel by James Fenimore
Cooper
moreover over the past few years I found
Freemont in his Virginia born wife
Jessie to be as clever bullheaded
combustible and ultimately as
fascinating as any character ever
invented by Margaret Mitchell and and
beyond that both John and Jesse like
rhett and Scarlett brought up brought a
powerful sense of drama to their own
lives to be honest the line frankly my
dear I don't give a damn could have been
written for John Fremont I mention these
things only as preface to saying that
one of the challenges of writing this
book of the past few years was the task
of separating separating out the public
and private dimensions of the Fremont's
lives this after all was a couple who
for a half-century lived very
self-consciously in in the public eye so
tonight I'd like
to touch on the highlights of John
Fremont's career and try to distill for
you the essence of Pathfinder my
biography of Freemont and I hope to show
you along the way while I think while
why I think he's worth remembering and
why I found him worth writing about
she'd begin by saying John Fremont lived
from 1813 to 1890 during his day
particularly during his early years he
was regarded as one of America's most
accomplished citizens though best known
as an explorer during his long life he
was also the Republican Party's first
presidential candidate he was a major
general for the Union during the Civil
War and he was a mining in railroad
magnate he was smart courageous handsome
at least for a while very rich he was
also controversial and famous indeed in
their day he and his wife Jessie were
regarded as one of America's most
celebrated couples by now
however the achievements of John Fremont
have largely fallen from public memory
in clips
eclipsed in many ways by those of Lewis
and Clark even in the West we're from
Nebraska tiket to California the
landscape teams with places named after
Fremont the specifics of his life have
faded so before I talk about the
specifics of Fremont's life and career I
think it might be useful tonight to rule
to begin by relating Fremont's
achievements to those of Lewis and Clark
with a broader context for understanding
the history of Western exploration I
think we might come to see John Fremont
is something more than an also-ran to
Lewis and Clark that said let me begin
by saying Lewis and Clark conducted
their famous transcontinental expedition
between 1804 and 1806 Fremont
expeditions the ones that make his
career took place four decades later
during the 1840s both Lewis and Clark
and Fremont led exploring expeditions
commissioned by the federal government
for the purpose of gathering scientific
and ethnographic information on the West
Lewis and Clark get credit for being the
first whites to cross what is now if the
continental United States
to the Pacific coast Fremont by contrast
gets credit from mapping and surveying
the more practical transcontinental
route to the south of the one that Lewis
and Clark explored eventually known as
the Oregon Trail that became the
principal corridor for Overland
immigrants into the far west but then
again while Lewis and Clark conducted
but one transcontinental expedition
Fremont conducted four moreover he
participated in two major surveying and
mapping expeditions of the Upper
Mississippi Valley John Fremont saw far
more of North America than Lewis and
Clark ever saw indeed in the long air
above before travelers parsed distances
with automobile odometers and frequent
flyer points Fremont probably saw more
of North America than any individual who
ever lived to understand Lewis and Clark
in Fremont's respective places in the
history of Western exploration it's
important to note that while by now
Lewis and Clark's famous journey has
become enshrined as the great epic of
our national history in fact it had
little immediate impact on their own day
Lewis and Clark's journals for instance
were not published until 1814 almost a
decade after their return from the West
and when they were published only 1,400
copies were printed
they sold slowly and this is an amazing
figure it would not be for another 90
years before an another edition appeared
of their journals by contrast when the
combined expedition the combined edition
of John Fremont first and second at
first and second expedition reports were
published in 1845 by the US Senate
10,000 copies were published they sold
quickly
the book quickly became a best-seller
and it was followed by numerous private
privately published editions and it was
widely translated for foreign editions
it was also widely serialized in
newspapers one of the things I stumbled
upon when I was researching this book
that in Thoreau's journals of his days
at Walden Pond
not the sa Walden but in the journals
Fremont mentions that he was passes some
of the time reading the serialized
version of Fremont's first expedition
report so the question is why did Lewis
and Clark have so little impact on their
own day and Fremont so much well in the
case of Lewis and Clark I think there
are two main reasons one is that the
route over the Continental Divide that
Lewis and Clark explored is was then and
now a remote rugged obscure location
neither then later did it attract much
traffic
I should note not long ago my wife and I
saw the wonderful IMAX Lewis and Clark
movie over at the Fernbank Museum and as
we were leaving a friend of ours who was
with us said you know my brother has
never been in in the West and was
thinking about going there this summer
and I was suggesting to him that perhaps
he should pick out a portion of the
Lewis and Clark route and either do some
backpacking or hiking along it but he
said you know since you've been working
on this Freemont book maybe maybe you
could tell me that maybe he should be
thinking about picking out a section of
the Fremont Rutten and I said no you got
it right the first time
much of the Lewis and Clark route is
today pristine for the simple reason
that it's it never attracted much
traffic Fremont's main transcontinental
route by contrast is is basically
interstate 80 so if you're if you're
going for tourism go with Lewis and
Clark if you're just trying to get
across the country go with Fremont I
think the other reason that the Lewis
and Clark expedition had so little
impact was that was that and I don't
think must be able to realize this but
there was no real immediate follow-up to
it by the federal government government
government-sponsored exploration of the
Far West really languishes for two or
three decades after Fremont's return
during those years most of what the
federal government learns about the West
is piecemeal information derived from
fur trappers who have no affiliation
with the feder
government so much of this information
it's is oral it's non systematic it's
it's unscientific some of its reliable
some is something less reliable it's not
until the 1830s as US political interest
in the West heats up that the federal
government concerned by then about
diminishing returns from its reliance on
fur trappers for geographic information
decides to get back into the business of
sending explorers into the Far West so
if that's why Lewis and Clark had so
little impact why did why did Fremont
have so much impact well the first
simple reason is that he mapped and
surveyed a practical route suitable for
wagons and Americans were ready to use
it on his first and second expeditions
which he mapped and surveyed of a
vaguely known loosely connected system
of Indian and trapper Trail stretching
from Missouri to Oregon this route was
later known as the Oregon Trail the
second reason I think that explains the
Fremont's impact was that it was his and
his wife Jesse's skills as popularizers
of the West prior to Fremont there had
been writings by Lewis and Clark Zebulon
Pike Zebulon Pike and other Western
explorers that offered entick accounts
of western travel but these narratives
tended to lack literary polish and they
never really gained a wide readership
conversely prior to Fremont there had
been books about Western travel by such
professional writers as Washington
Irving James Fenimore Cooper and others
that sparkled with literary polish in
one wide readerships but these were at
core works of literary imagination in
this lacked empirical veracity what
Fremont is able to do with assistance
from Jessie is to offer readers both a
polished narrative and scientific
authority these reports were cast as
first-person narratives they offered the
usual information one would expect from
such a report background on on flora
fauna and geography as well as vignettes
of frontier adventure
but also they included practical
information for travelers where to find
water fuel for fires how to avoid Indian
tackle attacks and if they really become
the base the the standard guide for
immigrants into the Far West these
reports nurtured a growing public
fascination with the West they also
established Fremont as a dashing public
figure for many readers the highlight of
the first expedition report was
Fremont's grandiloquent account of
animus of a peak that he believed to be
the highest in the Rockies into the in
the Wind River Range in today's southern
Wyoming in fact there are a number of
the number of Peaks higher than this one
but it you know it was a serious peak of
1313 1350 feet high
years later a stern readers had never
thought of anything that high in the
United States most speaks in the East
you know don't even break you know 5,000
feet years later the poet westernport
Joaquin Miller recalled reading the
first expedition report as a 13 year old
Midwestern farm boy I fancied I could
see Fremont's men hauling the cannon up
the savage battlements of the Rocky
Mountains flags in the air Fremont at
the head waving his sword with unknown
and unnamed it empires at every hand now
I began to be inflamed with the love of
action-adventure glory and great deeds a
way out yonder under the path of the
Setting Sun similar similarly poet Henry
Wadsworth Longfellow hearing his wife
read the first expedition report aloud
over several evenings but came so
captivated that he considered composes
composing an epic poem about the first
expedition he later confided to his
journal Fremont has particularly touched
my imagination what a wild life and a
fresh kind of existence but are the
discomforts many were less taken with
Fremont many found a kind of preening
quality to Fremont's work Ralph Waldo
Emerson complained of Fremont's apparent
obsession with quote how we must look
that said it's fair to say that many
Americans liked the way Fremont looked
and I think more to the point for my
money Jess John and Jesse Fremont
possessed a perfect pitched sense of
their audience and that dazed American
mind my own thinking is that these
reports captivated Americans that day in
the same way that Americans during the
1960's were captivated by the space race
and the landing on the moon in the sense
that in both cases I don't think the
public was really so into the science
associated with with the journey but
more it was just a an opportunity for
the swelling of national pride to see
their countrymen taking old glory to new
domains there's even a Cold War parallel
I think linking the two phenomena to wit
just as the National celebration of the
moon landing was heightened by the you
by the the then us rivalry with the
Soviet Union so the National celebration
of Fremont's triumphs in the West were
in heightened by the u.s. rivalry of
that day with Britain over Britain's
perceived interest in dominating the
West let me just give you a couple of
examples of some of the sort of press
that Fremont generated during that day
this is from the 18th for an eighteen
forty-five issue of the US magazine and
democratic review calling Fremont the
Pathfinder of empire the the the review
compares Fremont to Lewis and Clark
certainly as first explorers they were
entitled to great merit referring Lewis
and Clark but they lacked the science
which Captain Fremont carried into his
expeditions similarly this similarly the
Cincinnati Chronicle called the second
expedition which takes Fremont all the
way to Oregon and down into California
quote one of the most daring and
romantic achievements of modern
travelers the the newspaper goes on to
single out Fremont swinter crossing of
the Sierra during that expedition and
this was by the way the first known
crossing of the of the Sierra during the
winter it was not merely an expedition
but it was the crossing of the great
North American Andes in the midst of
winter
and two feet far exceeding the passage
of the alps by the ancient or modern
warriors this is probably a good place
to note that whatever admirable
qualities one might choose to find in
Fremont's explorations we should not
lose sight of the fact that his federal
expeditions belong to and cannot be
separated from the wider US project of
Indian Removal of that day of
dispossession of Indian lands one of the
darker chapters in our nation's history
while Fremont personally had good
relations with Indians most of the time
not always but most of the time what we
we need to keep in mind that one of the
key objectives of his explorations was
was to prepare the way for u.s.
militarization if not settlement of the
West specifically one of his charges was
to report on Indian conditions in the
West and stir and suggest the most
strategic look locales for the
construction of US Army forts to protect
Americans that the government assumed
would soon be venturing into the West a
few months ago at a academic conference
I was having a cup of coffee with a
colleague who had just reviewed my book
for the Los Angeles Times and he was
saying you know while I was reading
Pathfinder I kept trying to think of a
20th century equivalent of Fremont
someone whose career spans the century
and had and had so many reversals and
comebacks and I said yeah you know I was
I had the same thought along the way I
kept the only one I could come up with
was Frank Sinatra but that's that's
another that's another story you know
perhaps it perhaps another book who
knows let me just Fremont had a long and
varied resume let me just touch on a few
highlights he was as I mentioned earlier
he lived from 1813 to 1890 he was born
in Savannah Georgia actually down on Bay
Street in Savannah but he grew up in
Charleston South Carolina his father was
a refugee from France who in the United
States works as an antenna a teacher of
the French language his mother was the
daughter of a prominent Virginia family
on the subject of his
Aran's however the more salient fact in
understanding Fremont is less who they
were than the fact that they were never
married
that fact tattooed a stigma on Fremont
that haunted him through his life and
provided hurtful ammunition for for his
political enemies the father dies while
John was a child he grows up in
Charleston with a single mother there in
Charleston he as a boy he attracts the
first of several male mentors who will
shape his early years chief among them
is the savant and diplomat Joel Poinsett
points that introduces Fremont into a
circle of Charleston intellectuals and
political figures and from points that
Fremont also acquires the two beliefs
that really become the lifelong his lot
the lifelong foundation of his political
faith and most he beliefs were there is
a strong belief in the preservation of
the Union and a firm opposition to
slavery Fremont though like points that
was a southern though like points at a
southerner he remained throughout his
life opposed to slavery as a matter of
fact when when Fremont in 1856 is
nominated to become the Republicans
first presidential candidate the cries
of secession that rise from the south
then were every bit as vehement and
perhaps more so than the ones that
greeted the Republican Party's next
presidential nominee Abraham Lincoln
four years later points that also
arranges Fremont's admission into the
College of Charleston there he excels in
in math and sciences in these form the
foundation of his later mastery of
various navigational and exploration
sciences through points that also are
through point sets Democratic Party ties
and more specifically point sets
subsequent appointment as Secretary of
War in the administration of Democratic
President Martin Van Buren Fremont in
his early 20s is able to participate in
in several surveying and mapping
expeditions of the southern Appalachians
more importantly
set of ranges of commission is for free
- second-in-command on two major federal
response federally sponsored survey and
mapping expeditions of the Upper
Mississippi Valley basically today's
Wisconsin in the Dakotas in Minnesota
these are conducted under the leadership
of the French bar and explorer Joseph
Nicolette and it's it's really through
nickel at this the second of three
months major mentors that that Fremont
is able to hone really polish his
surveying and exploring skills in 1841
at the age of 28 is he's wrapping up his
work with Nicolette John by then living
in Washington elopes with Jesse Benton
the attractive brainy daughter of
Senator Thomas Hart Benton the the by
the way the great uncle of the of the
painter of the same name then Senator
Benton of Missouri is is really the
Senate's chief architect of US policy in
the West and so both both father and
daughter Senator Benton and Jesse over
the years will become serve as vigorous
defenders and political allies of
Fremont and as I mentioned earlier Jesse
a talented author assisted in writing
and editing the Fremont's reports with
Nicolette's death soon thereafter the
after the couple's marriage and Benton
support Fremont during the 1840s wins
the the three Commission's to lead the
government exploring expeditions there
in the into the far west that really
established his reputation I should note
that it's during the third expedition in
1846 Fremont is in California which was
then a Mexican province he becomes
caught up in an insurgency organized by
Americans living in California against
California's Mexican government weeks
later with the widely expected the
widely expected u.s. war with Mexico the
Mexican War and the arrival of US forces
in California free months small cadre is
regularized into
the US Army months later after a largely
bloodless conquest of California by the
by US forces Fremont wins the title of
conqueror of California I should note
that Fremont's winning of that title had
had little to do with any sort of
military prowess he displayed in
California or anything that he did on a
battlefield had more to do with the fact
that he just happened to be at the right
time in place to negotiate in Armas the
armistice by which Mexican fish
officials signed over California to two
US forces this is really the Mount
Everest of Fremont's life the the high
spot and and it quickly proves a
slippery slope for him you know
the famous line from f scott Fitzgerald
that there no second acts in American
life in American lives well Fremont had
many second acts following this but in
each act he plays an increasingly
diminished role he never again plays the
leading role he had during the early and
mid 1840s as a matter of fact the rest
of his world life is really an attempt
to regain the glory of those those years
in the wake of the u.s. conquest of
California Fremont is named territorial
governor of California only to within
weeks become drawn to become drawn into
a a dispute with a superior officer that
leads to his removal from office in a
year later court-martial in 18-49 a
state convention elects Fremont is one
of the new State of California's two new
US senators but that turns out to be a
brief and lackluster stint during the
80s during the 1850s he participates in
two disasterous privately funded winter
surveys through the mountains of
Colorado and New Mexico in a vain
attempt to find an all-weather railroad
passed through the southern Rockies and
of course in 1856 the Republicans
looking for an attractive candidate
without anti-slavery views tap him to
become their presidential candidate he
loses that race to Democrat James
Buchanan
when the Civil War comes thanks to
pressure from Radical Republicans in the
Senate Fremont is named a Major General
for the Union Army he takes and that
turns out to be a disappointing stent
and and really from the 1850s through
the rest of his life Fremont also
devotes much of his time and energy to
various business affairs on the eve of
the Mexican War
he had lucked into a Mexican land grant
in the Sierra Foothills
on which gold was later discovered but
and by the late 1860's he and his family
are living as Gilded Age aristocrats in
a Hudson River mansion
however by 1875 thanks to mismanagement
of his business affairs and poor
investments he's bankrupt and he really
spends the rest of his life in various
business schemes many having to do with
mining and railroads trying to recoup
that lost fortune his final turn on the
public stage comes between 1878 and 1881
when he serves as a territorial governor
of Arizona so the question you're asking
is why was Fremont unable to duplicate
these successes of his early years I
think there at least three reasons it
could come to mind
even during the halcyon days of
Fremont's career his during his
successful federal expeditions of the
1840s his achievements are constantly
being undercut by impulsiveness and
hunger for glory I'll give you one
example that this is this took place on
the return from the first expedition he
and his the exploring party are about to
head back down the Platte River Valley
and Fremont for the sheer hell of it and
that's the only way to explain this for
the sheer hell of it he he orders the
men to unpack and inflate an
experimental rubber raft that he had he
had purchased before the expedition he
orders the the rafted what they're there
he orders the raft to be put into the
water and
he and a half dozen or so men decide
they're going to go down a whitewater
portion of the the it's really at the
sweet confluence of the Sweetwater River
and the Platte River he tells the rest
of the exploring party I will see you
later and they take off downstream in
this on this whitewater well
that afternoon the the raft the capsizes
several men almost drown and the the
party Lee loses about half of the
biological and geological specimens and
botanical specimens they it so
meticulously collected during the
expedition and really and really for no
good reason
the second reason I thought has to do
with the lack of what we today call
people skills Fremont the man who served
under him tend to tended to really
admire him and they grew very loyal to
him so Fremont had a capacity for
winning allies but he also could be
stubborn and imperious with with a
career crippling disdain for authority
and a commensurate talent for winning
formidable enemies including most
famously Abraham Lincoln who by the way
was was kind of really forced to fire
Fremont from his stint as a Major
General we could talk more about that
later beyond all of us though I think
that Fremont was really one of the 19th
century's most vivid examples of the
Peter Principle
in action the the the principle that one
rises to one's level of incompetency to
it the hid the gifts his gifts is an
explorer
through his gifts have been explored
he's elevated in two successive theaters
that in which he really lacks the same
kind of gifts that he had as an explorer
in other words because he was a he was a
very competent leader of these small
exploring parties he become successively
a military commander a politician and a
business figure and he really had no
equivalent skills in these things and
these other endeavors that said though I
think that the failure of those later
years do nothing to diminish the
successes that he enjoyed during the
1840s during those three federal
expeditions he demonstrated admirable
leadership skills physical courage and
impressive competency is a sort of
one-man band a one-man band explorers
scientists serving often as the
expedition's chief geologist botanist
and navigator
this guy had a ferocious work ethic I
that it really makes Ben Franklin look
like a slacker
he worked beyond just leading the
expedition and tending to all of the
responsibilities that that entails he
worked he worked day and night of you
know stopping at midday and and rising
it at all hours of the night to fidget
with sextants chronometer z' barometers
and other equipment to determine and
record that day's location longitude
latitude and altitude but I think that
the real substantive secret of his
success was Fremont really possessed a
jewelers eye for a saying landscapes and
ascertaining how watersheds mountains
deserts prairies and valleys cohere into
a continental hole so what were the
tangible effects of this new vision of
the continent that Fremont popularized
well beyond finding a more practical
transcontinental route than the one
Lewis and Clark discovered Fremont also
ends up sparking the first mass
migration into the Far West
beyond that he puts Western mapmaking on
a scientific foundation there had been
this was by the way in a period in which
great mapmaking often had more to do
with removing than adding features to
the maps there had been other maps of
the West prior to free months but even
the best ones included accurate
information as well as half the truths
drawn from oral sources as well as
outright myths let me just give you two
examples of features that Fremont
removed from maps of the West one was
the the idea of the Buenaventura River
for centuries travelers in the West had
searched for and and some had thought
they had been able to see a portion of
the Green River or the cava or the
Colorado River they thought they had
seen this wine of insurer river it was a
river that was believed to rise on the
western slope of the Rockies and travel
and run across the deserts of the West
breaking through the Sierra and into the
Pacific Ocean and it was really the last
vestige of the notion of the great
Northwest Passage Fremont by making a
methodical north-to-south
survey down the eastern slope of the
Sierra is able to conclusively say it
ain't there there's no point of insure
River and remove it from maps the other
one other myth that Fremont removes from
maps is one that had been postulated by
Stephen long and Zebulon Pike to other
Western explorers earlier in the 19th
century this was the great American
desert it was a belief that from the
western bank of the Mississippi River
all the way to the Rockies there was
this desert of a sterile desert that
could never support you know a permanent
settlement or agriculture Fremont
through his surveys is able to
demonstrate that this area is far more
topographically and ecologically
variegated than then others had believed
and more amenable to human settlement
and agriculture then had been believed
in the past by the way it's it's a
measure of Fremont's in Perak
approach to map making that area is
uncrossed by his expeditions tended to
be generally remained blank on his maps
I might also note that it was through
Fremont's second expedition report that
Brigham Brigham Young learned about the
Great Salt Lake and decided to take his
Mormon co-religionists there from from
Illinois but related where they had been
at the time above and beyond all this I
think that Fremont really forced
Americans to reimagine the West and
thereby to reimagine America itself for
writers and intellectuals of his day he
gave he provided a new continental
template for writing and thinking about
America the West during three months to
a day is becoming more than just a
direction it's becoming a real place
with specific known features and many of
these features challenge Americans to
rethink their their notion of the idea
of America let me give you an example
for a Fremont's presentation of the grub
the Great Basin which is a term by the
way the coined by Fremont today's Utah
and Nevada his presentation of the Great
Basin is emblematic of that challenge to
Americans to rethink the continent to
what Americans prior to Fremont had been
familiar with Indians and deserts but in
the Great Basin Fremont presents Indians
living a very Spartan lifestyle on a
desert landscape that Fremont sees as
constituting a sort of primitive sublime
unlike any most white Americans had had
ever imagined on the their North
American continent let me just read a
passage from Fremont's report this is
his account of the Great Basin the whole
idea of such a desert and such a people
is a novelty in our country and it's and
excites asiatic not American ideas
interior basins with their own system of
lakes and rivers and often sterile are
common enough in Asia people still in
the elementary state of families living
in deserts with no other occupation than
the mere animal search for food may
still be seen in that
ancient quarter of the globe but in
America such things are new and strange
unknown and unsuspected and discredited
when related but I flatter myself that
what is discovered though not enough to
satisfy curiosity is sufficient too
excited and that subsequent explorations
will complete what has been commenced
the point here is that as the United
States is projecting its formal
geopolitical boundaries to the Pacific
during the 1840s Fremont is busy out
there creating a sort of geo
psychological foundation for that
expansion put it another way he's asking
Americans to abandon the final vestiges
of their traditional self images in
Atlantic seaboard oriented nation and
begin to think of themselves as a
continental nation with an Atlantic to
Pacific breadth one of the real
surprises for me in writing this book
was by the way was the extent to which I
learned that Fremont was a real
influence upon Longfellow and Whitman
and other writers of that day who had a
kind of self-conscious interest in North
American geography and and the varieties
of American identity or creating
varieties of American identity in
closing I'd like to just say a few words
about another theme of the book and
that's three months role in
transfiguring his days conception of
what Americans of that day were not
embarrassed to call the American Empire
to wit the the free months
sponsors like Senator Benton and others
who dispatched him into the West were
not so much interested in settling the
West as in establishing ports on the
Pacific for the purpose of trade with
Asia they weren't really interested in
the interior except to the extent that
Americans needed to cross over it to get
to the Pacific coast
why did Benton and so many of his
colleagues initially write off the far
west is a place for US settlement well I
mentioned one earlier is that the great
American desert under the spell of this
notion of the great American desert
Benton like many Americans never
believed that the interior west could be
settled moreover and this may be more
important the more import
reason as Benton as did many of
America's founders in particular
Jefferson subscribed to the philosopher
Montesquieu's caveat that nation-states
tend to break down when they try to
extend over great geographical expanses
in other words they never believed that
the United States as a nation-state
could fill the North American continent
could or would they saw the interior
west not as this place for settlement
but really isn't another Atlantic to be
crossed to get to the Pacific ports they
hope to establish Fremont however by
inadvertently discovering the West to be
far more ecologically variegated and
amenable to human settlement or to white
settlement in agriculture than
previously believed ends up transforming
the public comprehension of the West and
ultimately sparking settlement of the
interior in other words he refocuses the
American conception of Empire a vision
that had once been nautical and
outward-looking by the Leighton
by the late 1840s has become Continental
in inward looking focused more on
agriculture and domestic commerce than
mark mercantilist and maritime
objectives jesse fremont probably
offered the best epitaph to Fremont's
legacy in a letter to her husband light
in his life she wrote all your campfires
have become cities thank you very much
shall we yeah any questions yeah it was
curious about you started out with
comparing Lewis and Clark with Fremont
and how much impact do you think that
Meriwether Lewis dying shortly after
this you know tremendous accomplishment
has versus as you describe Fremont
always trying the rest of his life to
attain the same glory he had following
you know 1845 versus if he had died over
there Ellis had lived to become a yeah
Louis it's one of those what if
questions I mean I could I could imagine
that it would have had more impact but I
think the main reason that it mentions
Jefferson gave Lewis and Clark kind of
contradictory instructions he told them
to find the headwaters of the Missouri
River and and a practicable route across
North America the Assumption in that day
was that those were one in the same in
fact they're not they the headwaters of
the Missouri River are at a place called
lemma I pass in in the Bitterroot
Mountains on the border between Montana
and Idaho which by the way is a
wonderful place to camp I've camped
there and it's and you you go down a
gravel road for 50 miles to get there
but anyway it's it's not a it takes it
ends up taking travelers too far north
to be a practical route
so Fremont's root by the way is is is
basically connected by a place called
South Pass that's a very gradual it
presents travelers with a very gradual
approach a route across the Rockies so I
think I think the other reason was also
that there was no great pressure to
immigrate to the West during that day so
I you know I think they might have had
more impacted had Louis lived longer but
I don't I don't think it would have
substantively made a lot of difference
but who knows I mean it's a it's a
hypothetical I can understand why
anybody would be fascinated by Fremont
but what inspired your efforts to write
an entire book about him I mean the
academic answer is that my area as a
historian it tends to be Antebellum
nineteen pull it was to the century
political history but beyond that I
think in annotating that academic
interest I've always gravitated toward
writers like Whitman and Hart Crane and
Robert piercing and people like that
that it did that have a kind of
fascination with the breadth and
diversity of the American landscape
I wondered with this push westward if
Fremont ever cross pass was with Teddy
Roosevelt no no I mean not that I've
Fremont dies in 1890 and if so I haven't
come across it's an interesting question
rhythm it's like he crossed paths with
everyone everyone though I mean from I
mean this guy was really well-connected
I mean everyone from Hans Christian
Andersen to Queen Victoria to Jefferson
Davis to Herman Melville I mean he had
knew or met or you know fought with so
many different or allied himself with so
many people in this sort of the who's
who of the 19th century but late end and
early 19th century as and you know in US
presidents
I wondered if you could say a few words
about his relations with the American
Indians Native Americans there's a sort
of dual angle here as gather from on the
one hand his personal relations were
often good later on
does he have some especially as he is
associated with the destruction really
of the yeah I think on the only on the
issue of slavery one could argue that he
was ahead of his of his time on the
issue of Indians he was very much off
his time I mean I as I said he he tended
to have good relations with Indians he
encountered me actually by necessity if
there's nothing else I mean he's out
he's out in these places with you know
say 20 men and then they it's it's not
in their interest to to be belligerent
plus I mean now often they're they're
you know Indians are helping them with
you know directions and they're you know
bartering for food with them and such
but they're also instances in which you
know there is friction and and it
becomes violent done but I think the
larger point is that regardless of
whatever what relations Fremont
personally had with them
you can't untangle the his expeditions
from the larger us project of Indian
Removal you know in the wake of the
Louisiana Purchase u.s. policy is is to
move Indians west of the Mississippi by
the 1840s US policy has shifted to can
now that most of those Indians are
beyond the Mississippi and and that
whites are becoming interested in this
region the u.s. policy by then has
shifted to trying to confine Indians to
smaller and smaller parcels and and I
think it Fremont's day it was more
trying to keep Indians away from the
what
we came known as the Oregon Trail just
trying to keep whites and Indians apart
from one another and free months
journals are filled with you know
instances of saying you know this would
be a strategic place to you know to
build a US Army for it the other thing
that the US government was doing during
those days is purchasing for trading
posts from say the Hudson's Bay Company
and turning them into US Army facilities
these were places where settlers could
receive not only protection but that
could you know buy goods and such that
they needed for the rest of the trip to
the Far West to Oregon or California
yeah you said you had a hard time
thinking of a comparable figure from the
20th century
if Freeman had been born in the 20th
century could he have been a great man
in the 20th century is he someone that
is so much his skills were so it were
suited to the 19th century and that was
his time I think I'm gonna duck that
question I mean it's it's it's really
it's it's it's the hypothetical I'd I
don't know how to give you a good answer
do it yeah
yes
I guess it's the question we wonder of
all of our authors so what are you
working on next I'm giving myself a
chance to cool down from from this one
and I'm thinking about something to do
with the this same period but the early
u.s. involvement with China and the
Pacific trade but I haven't isolated the
you know figure or principle story or
vignettes that I would use to tell this
story be a good opportunity to spend
some time in China which is another
long-standing interest how long did it
take you to research and write this book
I worked on it over five I guess five
years but I figured it out not long ago
I think it was just two solid two or
three solid years of work and I was I
was teaching and doing other things
during this five-year period
I had a nine-month stent at the
Huntington Library in Los Angeles and
you know where I that was the only
responsibility I had to work on this
book and I also while I was there I got
around to the archives in California
that are that were key to the project I
should add the Fremont's papers are
scattered all over the country the chief
repositories though tend to be the
Library of Congress the Huntington
Library the the Bancroft library at UC
Berkeley
I also found a lot of materials at the
use of UCLA's special collections but I
mean I started actually at in Charleston
you know the South Carolina Historical
Society I and actually I found Fremont's
grades at the College of Charleston he
was booted out by the way when one
semester shy of his graduation for a
fair to a lack of attendance but when he
was there he did well but then they
later they later gave him an honor
degree but anyway I found there were a
lot of materials at the New York
Historical Society and end up in the New
York Public Library and I probably used
all in all about 30 different Ark
archives around the country I mean
that's one of the logistical
difficulties of a project like this is
trying to figure out how to get to all
of these places some I couldn't
personally get to I would hear about a
letter you know it's you know one place
that would have maybe two letters and I
would you know just get those through
you know fax or mail or something you
you really learn to count on the depend
upon the kindness of strangers when
you're doing this this sort of strange
as being archivists and librarians who
help you out when you can't get to these
places and any other questions yeah
I was just wondering if he did anything
interesting with his wealth when he had
it did he invest in anything or give to
any organizations or do anything with
that what in investments are kind of
conspicuous consumption spending he
lived very well during this I don't know
decade or so probably less than a decade
when he lived on the Hudson Hudson River
I mean he bought I found one record of
his paying I think I can't remember the
price that's in the book I mean I think
of a few thousand dollars for an Albert
Bierstadt painting of Yosemite for
instance which the thousand dollars is a
lot of money in those days he bought the
one of his idols was the Explorer the
german explorer von humboldt and when
upon Humboldt's death he buys most of
unbolts library personal library and
they and they traveled a lot at one
point they they had a house in Paris and
as far as his investments he could have
used some it could have used Charles
Schwab or someone he he invested in a
lot of railroad projects and you know
canal building schemes and things that
just never never worked out actually
when he died in 1890 he was living in a
Jesse was living in Los Angeles but he
was on an extended business trip to New
York he died in a resident hotel but at
that period in his life he and Jesse
were trying to capitalize on the on the
first real estate boom in Los Angeles
this is shortly this is in the 1880s
shortly after the first trunk of the
Transcontinental Railroad reaches Los
Angeles that's that's the first real
real estate boom in Los Angeles in
Fremont was trying to capitalize on that
and never succeeded yeah one of the
great irony
or sort of sad irony as his life is that
he he did so much to stimulate the the
growth of the West's infrastructure and
that he was really never able to profit
from it he did briefly through his gold
mining activities but that that
eventually went south on I just wondered
also you had mentioned the of course
naturally it might have his explorations
might have influenced the Mormon
activities going west to the Great Salt
Lake and Brigham Young did he have
active relations with the Mormons during
that period say from the 1850s to I
would say the death of Brigham Young did
he did he have any strong reactions to
the Mormons did he take any special
activities with regard to polygamy for
example as you know having previously
taken activity with regard to a slavery
or was that something that never really
sort of emerged as an issue for him if
it did I found no record of it in that
in a way archival search yes sir during
your five-year relationship with the man
did you develop any likes or dislikes
about him or his personality do you ever
have do you have any friends where if
you're thinking of inviting into
somewhere you you sort of tell people
before he before he gets there you've
got to give this guy a wide berth he's
someone I would love to go traveling
with in the West but I don't know that I
would want him to manage my stock
portfolio now I think you know he he was
very much a mixed mixed bag I mean he
tended to be very beloved by the men who
served under him in these exploring
parties but he also could be very
imperious and distant
and his pompous so there was a biography
of Dylan Thomas that I read years ago in
which the the biographer said that
Thomas had this capacity for seeming
very different to everyone who met him
and I think there's something of that to
Fremont he's he's kind of hard to pin
down that way what it was it caused him
to have a problem with authority well
the easiest answer and it's the the
standard one the most biographers of him
is that the you know the lack of a
father of a strong male figure in his
life
and I'm sure there's there's something
to that
and I really never came across any any
sort of rosetta stone for understanding
that I might else III think he was in
fairness to him he was he was very smart
and ambitious and I think that that
alone a lot of people the wrong way I
found a letter a diary from a an
infantryman in the US Army during the
Mexican War I found this diary in the at
the California Historical Society
archives in San Francisco and there's a
line in there about free - it I wish I
could marry a senator's daughter and
just go all over the place doing
whatever the hell I want to do like this
guy Fremont I mean and there was also a
lot of resentment from West Point
graduates in the army
I mean he really was a he was
accomplished but he was also a kind of
tireless self-promoter of himself so I
think there are other factors to
consider beyond just the you know the
biographical circumstances of his birth
his family relations okay well anyway
thank thank you thank you for coming out
to Tom Chaffin his author of Pathfinder
John Charles Fremont and the course of
American Empire it's published by Hill
and Wang a division of fair straus and
giroux visit FSG books com for more
information next week on public lives
the atheist